Okay. Good Morning Ladies and
gentlemen. My name is Craig Wright,
and this is listening to music and most
basic course that the department of
music has to offer. It's aim is to
teach you how to listen to music.
Wait a minute, you say that's
preposterous. I listened
to music all the time.
I got what?
My iPod,
I downloading MP three files
continually swapping files.
Uh, I've gotten my car. Uh, what, what did
we call those things in the automobile?
Where you, is it a dat tape that you
can take your iPod and plug it into the,
you're the stereo system in your car?
I've got that. I listened to music,
my dorm room off my computer
and the bookstore, wherever.
I Bet I listened to a lot more
music than you do. You old goat.
Uh, and, and you're
right. You probably do.
But what kind of music are
you listening to? Well,
probably pop music and that's fine.
That's okay. Fair enough. Pop Music.
But are you getting the most out
of this particular experience?
Are you getting the most out
of your listening experience?
I contend that perhaps you are not,
that,
that you are not maximizing the time
using that time most profitably.
A,
how do I know this?
What makes me think that you are not
getting as much as you possibly can out of
your music? Well experienced
to some degree, but also, uh,
an experiment that I did just last
weekend. I have four children.
The last of the four has now turned 17.
So I said last weekend, Chris, he's,
you know, always with the IPAD. Chris,
what are you listening to? Go Away.
You're bothering that kind of thing.
You're ruining my life again.
So, uh, but uh, come on, let,
let me listen to this. Let me,
this is, what are you listening to?
So I listened to it and I said,
all right,
here you listen to this and tell me
what you're hearing. And what did,
what was he tracking?
He was tracking the text.
He was tracking the beat of the
peace. I ask him, well, what,
what's the mode of the piece?
What's the meter of the piece?
What's the base doing?
Can you follow the baseline there?
Can you identify any chords in this
particular piece? Nothing. Zero.
And this from a reasonably sophisticated
kid who's had 12 years of serious cello
lessons. And that brings up, I suppose,
a point,
uh,
that although I don't know
much about your music,
I think I can teach you a great deal
about your music by using the paradigms of
classical music. So we were talking a lot
about classical music in here, Mozart,
Bach, Beethoven. It will
be the locus of our course.
How many of you already
listen to classical music?
Raise your hand. Okay, great.
A lot of you, and that's wonderful. I'd be
interested to know, gentlemen down here,
how do you do this?
Is it streaming off of your computer?
Are you downloading MP three
files and saving them? How?
Tell me how do you do it?
You go to youtube. All right, very
interesting. I should have known that,
but I didn't.
You go to youtube and you listen there.
Anybody else do it a different
way? Yes. On the radio.
Okay, that's interesting.
We'll come, we'll come back
to that point. Anything else?
Anybody? Yes. Okay. Your
parents' cds or records.
That's wonderful.
They have sort of the old technology here,
but some of those old, old recordings
might be, uh, a very, uh, very, very, uh,
good.
Now here's a question for you.
Why would we want to listen to
classical music? Why do, why, uh,
who, who just answered
the question for me here,
those folks that raised your hand, what
a gentlemen here again, I'll pay your,
your, my sacrificial lamb this morning.
Uh, why do you like to listen to,
why would you want to listen
to classical music? Okay,
very interesting. Um, national
public radio asked exactly this,
uh, this question in a
survey a year or so ago,
and they got the following
principle responses back.
Why do people listen to classical music?
One,
it helps them relax and relieve
stress. So that's, this is,
this is perhaps the principle
reason to helps us center the mind,
allowing the listener to concentrate.
Three,
classical music provides a vision of a
better world vision of a better world,
a refuge of beauty, of majesty,
perhaps of even of, of love.
And sometimes,
at least for me personally,
it suggests that there might be
something out there, God or whatever,
bigger than ourselves.
And it asks us to think
sometimes think about things.
Uh, the, that's what I think these great
fine arts do great literature, poetry,
painting, music. They show
what human beings can be,
the capacity of the human spirit.
They suggest to us as indicated.
Maybe there is something,
a larger spirit out there,
then our sales and they get us to think
they could get me to think frequently
about what I'm doing on this earth.
What are you doing on this earth? No,
don't answer that.
What am I doing on this earth with
regard to this particular course?
What am I trying to accomplish in here?
Uh,
well maybe two things.
One,
change your personality,
change your personality.
I want to make you a richer person,
a broader person by instilling you with,
uh,
an an ending,
a deep and abiding understanding
of classical music.
So that's part of this. And not just here
for Yale, but for your life after Yale.
Uh, I would hope that how you
lead your life 10 years from now,
20 years from now,
30 years from now,
would have been significantly influenced
by this particular experience in this
course. And secondly, if I'm
successful in my teaching,
I will accomplish this second aim here
I will impart to you a love of classical
music you through later on you after Yale,
your attendance at concerts, buying
one fashion or another, downloading MP,
three files with iTunes or
whatever it happens to be.
Maybe being members of your local
symphony board, opera companies,
something like that, may be giving
music lessons to your children.
You will become the purveyors of
classical music thereafter. You,
the intelligentsia,
the next generation will be those that
preserve this great treasure of western
culture. And it is a great
treasure of Western culture.
Okay,
how are we going to do all of this?
How are we going to accomplish these
two things on our list of agenda here?
Uh, what are the mechanics of the
course? Did you all get a syllabus?
Everybody's got a syllabus. I should
have brought one up here, but I didn't,
it doesn't matter. Uh, first
three, four weeks or so,
we'll be following the elements of music,
rhythm,
melody and harmony,
and then a test.
Next we will deal with what's the most,
arguably the single most important thing
when we listened to any piece of music.
And that is it's musical form.
Here's a question for you.
I was thinking about this the other day
or so preparing the lecture for today.
What's the most common type of musical
form in pop music when you listen to pop
music? Do you ever think
about the form of the music?
Can anybody name a form of pop music?
Any one for him?
Yeah.
Well maybe verse and chorus. Think
about that. That shows up a lot,
a lot of stuff.
And we'll come back to that.
We'll talk about version of course
when we get to the issue of form. Uh,
and then toward the end of the course
we will turn to the question of musical
style. How does a piece of Pop music
differ from a piece of classical music?
We sort of all know this intuitively,
but can we articulate why this particular
difference about musical style was
driven home to me the other days. Last
Friday I was walking across the campus.
Maybe you saw this to
corner of Elm and college.
There's a large flat bed truck out there
and there were these people on this
truck getting you trying to
sell you audio equipment. Uh,
and they had a big banner up there.
It said pump up your room. Okay,
so then to encourage
you to pump up the room,
they had music playing and this is the
kind of music that they had on that
flatbed truck.
Okay. So I'm feeling, feeling
very pumped up at that particular point
and my cell phone rings.
Okay, this is true.
My cell phone rings and because one has
the capacity now days to select your own
ringtone. Right? I have mine
selected not to that sound,
but to Mozart.
So I hear this sound on my telephone.
Linda's moving this around here,
just a second.
And it will give us a sense of the
difference in style between pop music and
classical music. How does this,
but what we're here differ,
can you give me say three or four reasons
why what we're about to hear differs
from what we just heard.
Okay.
Mozart
[inaudible].
Okay. Let's just stop right there
and you can go onto the next. Uh,
can anyone tell me what, what's
different difference between these two?
What's the Po, what did the Depop
piece that it's rave till dawn.
That's my own, that album. I'll have, you
know, rave till dawn. Gentlemen back here.
Okay.
Uh, yes, that's probably true. That's
probably true as a general observation,
whether it comes through clearly
on these two, this comparison,
I'm not quite so sure. Uh, but they're,
I wouldn't say there's a great
deal of detail in the first one.
There's a lot of repetition. That's
where I, you know, once that gets going,
it goes for a long period of time.
Anything else? Yes. Oh, melody.
Which one had the melody?
Yeah. [inaudible] Tata.
Tata. The first I couldn't pick out
any melody at all. It was all what?
Rhythm and beat.
Okay.
So repetitious rhythm beats
strong pulsation to it. Uh,
what was making that sound?
What were the instruments playing in the,
okay.
In the Mozart there were violin,
so acoustical instruments as a as opposed
to synthetic sound with regard to the
pop music.
So what we will be doing
is differentiating pop
from classical and also
differentiating within styles of classical
music. You're driving down the road,
you who was the FM listener over there,
you turn on your radio,
your car radio to your FM
classical music station.
And what number approximately
would you go to?
Okay,
yeah. Or anywhere your
home camp edition. Okay.
98 that's pretty high. What
to what town is that? We will,
oh that's Chicago. Well they're
elevated people in Chicago and sure.
Normally normally where you go is
all the way down in the low numbers,
particularly here in Connecticut it's
a 89.5 90.1 90.5 my favorite is 91.5
generally speaking,
you want to find a classical music,
you go to the left of your FM dial and
fish around down there and your national
public radio. Okay, so that's how we do
it. But you've got your car radio going.
Music comes on.
Is it broke or romantic?
Is it medieval or modern is a
Bach or is it Beethoven? Well,
those sorts of answers,
those sorts of issues of the sorts of
things that we'll get to when we come to
the question of musical style toward
the end of the course. Okay. Materials,
materials.
A textbook here is the textbook.
It is my own textbook listening to music.
Now in the fifth edition.
Uh, I'm very proud of it actually. It's
used across all across the United States.
Uh, it used across the world about to
come out in a Chinese edition for Heaven's
sakes. Um, what was it?
It was simply my lecture notes from
this particular course that I've been
teaching here for a long time.
I had these lecture notes.
I had all of these listening exercises.
Basically just put it in a textbook.
So this is all material for Yale students,
you know,
material design here at Yale for Yale
students at the back of the book,
I think I took mine out, but the back of
the book you will see wrapped with it,
an intro CD introductory CT might be
interested to know that a lot of the
material, they're actually recorded by
Yale undergraduates. We paid them for it.
We paid people across
the street school music,
but this again is kind of
native local Yale produce here.
So we have to hit,
we get the textbook and then with the
textbook we recommend getting access to
this six CD set.
This material will be necessary to do
the listening exercises for the course,
which is sort of the
backbone of the course.
There are a couple of copies of this on
reserve in the music library and you can
go over there inside of of
Sterling Memorial Library
and do the listening there
if you want.
But one way or another you got to get
ahold of this if you decide to buy it.
It has one particular virtue and that is
you end up with an excellent library of
classical music that will
last you for a lifetime.
Years after the fact.
I get email from emails from students
nowadays, they usually begin,
hey professor or yo professor,
something like this.
I lost CD four to my six CD set.
Can you get me a replacement?
Yes I can.
And I do send them a replacement. Not
too hard to do. Send them a replacement.
So if you get the CD set,
not only do you get a wonderful
beginning library of classical music,
but in effect you get a lifestyle
lifetime service contract with it.
Uh, okay. Requirements. You
can see this on the sheets too.
You've got the couple of tests here.
We have to write a short music paper.
We're all going to go to the concert.
I concert,
I think this year we're going to go here.
The Saybrook,
a youth orchestra and I put
on the, uh, a sheet this year.
I think I'm going to try to
count 5% for class participation.
We will be taking attendance
in the lecture. Yeah, I
know it's babies. I'm sorry,
but I take this very seriously.
I really do.
It's my lifeblood.
And I want you to take this seriously too.
I want you to come to class. I want
you to come, come to lectures. Um,
so we have the two lectures
each week that you'll come to.
Sections are also also mandatory.
We have three wonderful
specially selected a in here.
We'll introduce you to the next time.
So come to two lectures,
one section and do the work regularly.
Now sections,
they start on Thursday and go through a
Monday cycle. They do not start tonight.
They start next Thursday in the cycle.
You can go online and sign up there,
but you're still shopping. So we're not
starting sections tonight. You may not,
may or may not be taking this course.
Do the assignments,
these listening exercises on time.
Music is an orally perceived phenomena.
Music isn't orally perceived phenomena.
You can't cram information about music,
the sound of music into your
head the night before a test,
the way you might be able to in an
English course or a history course.
Uh,
the way we hear music,
the way our mind processes music is very,
very different from this
other kind of information, uh,
very different from history or
economics to make this point.
Let me see if we can get my helper here,
technical person to bring up a slide
for me. And my question to you is,
as this slide comes up,
is the following, uh,
where in the brain is
music processed primarily?
Where, where do we process?
Anybody know the answer to that?
You buy take psychology courses and
a neurobiological courses. Yeah,
she had a lady out here.
Do you have a sense of that
left side of the brain that sounds like
the old, maybe the old creativity theory.
Uh, could we, and that's possible.
Um, uh, in, in a way it's, it's,
it's correct. Um, oh. Anything more
specific? All right. Here's our brain.
We took this off of the Internet.
All right.
That's why it's all in French because
it's not copyrighted and we have to be
careful with that in here with these
camera rolling. Camera's rolling.
So we have the 12
separate browser on that.
It just means the brain stem and
the cerebellum and then the t,
the temporal lobe, the frontal lobe,
the parietal and the occipital lobe.
So where is music and language process?
Anybody here's just
somebody raising your hand.
Wow.
Yes. The temporal lobe is
where your hearing goes on.
It doesn't matter whether you're hearing
language or whether you're hearing
music.
Most of the processing happens
in the primary auditory cortex,
both left and right of the temporal lobe.
If you're factoring in,
let's say I had to remember to
play something at the keyboard,
well there I might be factoring in the
frontal lobe because much of the short
term memory in particular
is in the frontal lobe.
Let's say I went to play a piece.
I didn't think about that
actually a minute ago.
I didn't even know what he's going
to play, but I remembered that.
Am I thinking back then? Oil starts
and see and let's get you up there.
It's got a G. No, it's like athletes.
It's muscle memory. You know,
you do that 8 billion times in your
life and you can hit a good top spin
backhand a,
it's muscle memory and that happens in
the Perry that's mostly in the perinatal
here. I've got a score
up here. If I'm looking,
then I've got the visual cortex engaged.
So doing music, if I'm sight reading,
playing, it's a very complex thing, but
most of the, let's shut this down there.
We'll go back to the other screen.
Most of this music and language
processing happens in the,
the, as I mentioned, the left
and right auditory cortex. Um,
therefore, where am I going
with all this? Therefore,
the pedagogical techniques
that we use in teaching,
listening to music are virtually
identical to those that we use in teaching
language.
There's a great deal of similarity here
because it's just processing sound. Uh,
this was a point,
I was listening to some national
public radio thing the other day.
Can you get my screen back up full
size here so I can see this? Um, uh,
listening to something that had a
psychologist talking about the correlation
between sound and music and they said it
was something about music is sometimes
very strange, sometimes very
strange, sometimes very strange,
sometimes very strange.
The, the, the, the,
the TTP and that sort of brought
home to me, the Texas irrelevant.
The idea that music really is sound
and that language is just sounds,
it's a very thin line between the two,
but we therefore used the same pedagogical
methods in the sense that we've got
to do the following.
If you ever read the course descriptions
of French one 15 or Chinese language
basic intro to Chinese, they say,
I think I wrote it down here. Uh,
this process of gradual assimilation.
Yes,
daily participation in language
labs required. So daily,
daily is the key thing here. You've
got to do this gradual assimilation.
So learning to listen to music is
just like listening to language.
We've got to do a little bit every day.
You got to turn in these listening
exercises in a regular fashion and come to
class.
This is a beginning course.
I assume that you know nothing starting
from ground zero here and build it up.
Uh, alright. I've talked,
I've droned on here.
Let me ask you if you have questions
about, uh, the course generally.
Do you have questions of me at this point?
Yes.
Gentleman in the back,
the formats of the tests will be
very clearly laid out for you.
There'll be a little bit of written work,
there'll be a fair amount of listening.
Uh,
you will be given a list of pieces that
you'll have to prepare for a little bit
and then we will play out of the,
out of those particular pieces.
But most importantly,
I will give you a prep sheet.
Each test comes in advance with a prep
sheet telling you how to get ready for
that particular test. Good. Good question
though. Thank you. Anything else?
Okay. If not, let's go onto the following.
We're going to have a diagnostic quiz in
here. We're taking a quiz the first day.
Now that's on the back
of your hand out there.
This is not really a quiz cause we're not
gonna. We're not gonna collect it. Uh,
you can throw it away,
going out.
It's in here to intend
it to do two things.
One to show you something about the method
that we will be using in here and the
two to show you something
of the level of this course,
the level of the course,
the questions that I'm
asking on this quiz,
questions asked on the quiz or the types
of things we would expect you to know
at the end of the course. Not
now, but at the end of the course.
Some of these are difficult.
Uh,
so if you find yourself getting
most of these answers correct,
then don't take this course. You'd be
wasting your time wasting your money here.
So don't, don't do this. If you, if you
find at the end of this, you got 16, 17,
18 of these, correct. All right,
let's start with a little bit of
classical music here. And this, uh,
engages questions one and two,
who is the composer of the piece that
you're about to hear and what is its title
or what's it call?
Okay.
Okay. So let's see. Let's do,
I'm going to ask Linda to cue the next
piece here while we talk about that.
Just for a moment. The composer,
anybody know the composer of this?
Raise your hand. Okay. Um, some
people do, some people don't.
A gentleman over here. Dark shirt.
Okay. That is Beethoven. Look big, Ben.
Beethoven, and do you know the name of
the piece? Okay. Symphony number five.
Now if you're sitting next to this
gentleman, Oh God, this guy knows so much.
I'm going to, I'm going to go
down the tube in this course. No,
don't be intimidated by,
by this. As I say, we're,
we're going to build
everybody up here together.
So that was Beethoven's Fifth Symphony,
the beginning of it.
A famous passage in the
history of classical music.
Let's listen to another composition here.
Who's the composer of this and what in
what composition is this piece used?
Probably
enough. It there. So who has the composure
of that? Anybody know the answer?
Fewer people do. A young lady out here
in the green, did you have your hand up
again? Beethoven? What's
the, what's the win?
What composition does Beethoven
used this particular piece,
they know generally here. Okay,
in the ninth symphony. Again,
if you're saying, oh, I'm getting
really worried now, don't be,
don't be worried here. Uh,
okay. So Ninth Symphony.
Now I believe that music
works a magical potion,
a magical spell on it. Music gets
us to do particular kinds of things,
gets us to feel particular kinds of ways.
And I think these two pieces by the same
composer get caused us to feel very,
very different cause a different mood,
different psychological
state to come over us.
One of them goes this way.
Okay.
And the other,
I want to do a little experiment.
I've never done this before,
never done this before, but
um, like to do the following.
And that is to ask you,
uh,
to think about what mood each
piece causes you to fall into.
And I've put some adjectives up on the
board up there and I've grouped them by
R's and L's because I'm going to ask you
to raise your right hand if you respond
one way, uh, to a piece and your
left hand if you respond the other.
So under the our group there,
we've got positive, happy,
secure. Under the El Group,
we've got a negative, anxious, unsettled.
So I've chosen pieces maybe with slightly
different fields here. Let's see.
Let's see what we do with
this. Now. A piece number one.
Oh,
how'd you feel about that?
Now here's piece too.
Uh,
all right. So here's one.
If I'm gonna play it again.
Yeah.
If you raise your right hand or
left hand as your response to that.
Okay,
here's piece one.
MMM.
Right hand or left hand.
All right.
So those of you that are raising your
hand and some aren't raising their hands,
but that's okay.
Uh,
those of you a unit almost unanimously
say that the Beethoven Fifth Symphony
sounded somewhat ominous to,
is somewhat faithful to us.
And the Beethoven Ninth
Symphony conversely has a
different sort of feel to it.
Indeed.
Does anybody know the title
of the Beethoven Ninth
Symphony was the setting of a
poem by Friedrich Schiller
called Ode to Joy. Oh to joy.
So how does Beethoven go about
making the Ode to Joy Joyful?
What does he do here? This is what
we're going to be doing in our course.
We're going to be
zeroing in on this music.
Can anybody tell me why
to a person in this room?
We all responded positively to the Ninth
Symphony and somewhat more anxiously to
the fifth symphony.
You have to tell me one thing.
Okay. Major and minor. Now
once again, you, you're,
you're out here in front.
You've been listening to your parents'
records and cds and, uh, so, so maybe, Eh,
uh, I'm delighted that you know this, but
maybe this is too far too far. Um, uh,
below what your d your dignity here.
So, but, but good for you. Alright,
we've got this idea of major chords and
minor chords. So let me ask you this,
uh, which I think this is a quiz question
here, would probably number five,
which is this a major chord or a minor
as opposed to,
oh,
the first one is a minor chord.
The second one is a major chord.
We could call them triads and we'll be
talking about with that. Yes. Before.
So that's one reason, major versus
minor. Here's a question for you.
What about this?
Let me take the rhythm out of it.
That's a bit skippy, isn't it? It
doesn't move around a lot. Whereas the,
if I take the rhythm out
of the night symphony,
really Beethoven,
they're just going up and down a scale.
So it's very conjunct.
We have the difference between
conjunct music with the
disjunct music
and that perhaps adds to the unsettled
quality of the Beethoven Fifth Symphony.
Here's something else,
and I guess it's a quiz question.
I think I'm asking you there.
Uh,
it has to do about a home pitch.
Music gravitates around a home
pitch. Uh, and in the Beethoven Fisam
[inaudible]
we still haven't gotten the home pitch.
We go that far.
We still haven't heard the homepage.
Anybody's sing the homepage.
[inaudible]
um,
but he hasn't given it to us and maybe
why this sounds so this junk and so
unsettled,
uh,
apart from the skippy nature of the
melody is that we are not given at the
outset the home pitch.
Whereas with the Ninth Symphony,
second phrase,
that's the home pitch there and we all
feel sort of secure in that whole pitch.
There's another reason I think these
two sound differently and that is the
following. What's the direction generally
of Beethoven's fifth symphony here,
downs generally going down.
So the direction that music goes can
also affect how we feel about it,
our mood about it.
So I think the next question,
I play another piece for going to play
this from to piano a little bit. Um,
and I ask you the name of
the composer of this piece.
It's a little bit less well known than
maybe not a what it's called and when in
the history of music it was written,
if I know that piece in
the name of the composer.
Yeah.
Okay.
Debbie,
you see a French composer writing at
the end of the 19th century in the
impressionist style and the pieces
called Moonlight Clair de Lune.
But again, you make, you'll come out
of this course four months from now.
You'll know all of this stuff. Now
you're not supposed to know any of this.
What I'm interested in is your
emotional response to this.
How do you feel about this music?
What kind of mood does it put you in?
How do you feel about that?
Anybody wanted, tell me about that.
Okay.
Whoops. I heard is I heard nice
and loud please. Serene. Yeah.
Serene. Why does it feel serene? Boy,
I wish I could play my rave till dawn CD.
Right?
Ciao.
Okay. There's no beat
to it. All right. The,
it's very language in of the pulse here.
It's very understated in terms of a,
B,
you'd be hard pressed to identify
what the meter of that is.
So that's one reason. And of course
the what, where am I going with the,
the next important point about what's
happening in this music that makes us feel
serene,
relaxed because it's all going down.
And only when we get here,
do our spirits soar upward
at that particular point,
at that particular point.
So again, direction in music also is
important with how we respond to it.
So what do we, what are we going
over here? Major versus minor,
a disjunct versus conjunct. What else? Um,
strongly felt tonal key,
which is called,
I don't know if I mentioned that they're
not the tonic key. The tonic pitch,
the tonic pitch there. And this
idea of the direction of the music.
All of these will have
to be thinking about,
thinking about as we listen
to music in this course.
Uh, okay. Now let's see.
Okay.
I think I want to do the following.
Yeah.
Here's a question for you.
Here's a question, completely
different subject here.
Um,
what are the two dimensions
of music dimensions of music?
I think about dimensions of
painting or architecture perhaps,
but what are the two dimensions of music?
Ever thought about that?
Can anybody give me one? Well
pitch. Oh yeah, I'm sorry.
Okay. Pitch. And what would
the other one be? Time. Okay.
Pitch and time or pitch and duration.
Excellent.
So those are the two dimensions of music.
And we'll deed,
we could even call them the axes of music
because we tend to think of pitch on a
vertical access. We talk in terms
of high pitch and low pitch,
although we'll find tune that next time.
And then we had this
idea of duration or time,
which we tend to write out in symbols
that move from your left to right,
left to right. So what I'd like to
do now is focus on a piece that, uh,
emphasizes for grounds.
Just the first axes pitch.
And here is a question for you.
Uh,
how many have you have you have
heard regards Strauss's also Brock.
Zahra through stripe?
Yeah.
Okay. How many in a night,
baby? Courageous here.
How many have not heard Ricard
Strauss is also sprocket?
Xero through is to raise
your hand nice and big. Okay.
The overwhelming majority of people wrong.
You all have heard this many times.
It's used continuously. A movie score,
television, radio commercials.
It's all over the place.
As soon as I start to play it, uh,
at least once we get into it, you'll,
you'll feel, oh yeah, I've heard that.
So this is a piece by Strauss where
he's trying to resurrect the content or
mirror the content of a philosophical
novel by Friedrich Neetsy,
thus spoke Zahra through stress.
And it's about the unleashing of human
capacity as it comes forth from the
primordial earth here and
Strauss in attempting to do this,
we'll use the orchestra duty picked here.
In this particular case,
perhaps the rise of human power may be
as metaphorically represented by the sun.
So here is Strauss depicting
the rise of the sun.
And the first question I think that you
have on the quiz here is the following.
Um,
what keyboard instrument is playing here?
It's a keyboard instrument.
So let's listen to just a little
bit of this please. Linda.
Yeah.
Okay. Let's stop there. Because of the
condition of the amplifier this morning,
you can't really hear what that is.
What that is is an organ pipe of the type
of Oregon that we have over in Woolsey
Hall. 32 feet tall. This
gigantic sounds right.
Oh,
down there. So that's what
he's trying to set up. Okay.
Then a brass instrument enters and what
is the name of this brass instrument?
Okay. Yeah, go ahead.
Precaution instrument.
Yeah,
let's stop it there.
So the brass instrument is the,
is a trumpet. Okay. That's what
that is. It's coming up there.
Let's talk about what we've
got on the board here.
We can see we have these
low pitches of wool.
Oh, what did I just say? Bom. Bom.
Almost the same sounding pitch,
right? Well, we'll talk about this.
This is called an octave.
It has to do with frequency ratios that
will go into a little bit next time.
So he's coming up initially
just through octaves. Um,
then the next page on the trumpet,
Bom Bom is actually the
interval of the fifth he m bomb.
That's a fourth,
but it happens
to produce an octo bom bom against that.
Then the first time
bom bom.
So he came up a major third there and
then quickly backed off it just a half
step lower,
which completely gave it a different
feel to bright shiny major and in dark
minor.
Then a percussion instrument came in.
Uh,
he may know what that was.
Okay. Um, tell me what it was.
Nice and loud.
Yell it out there.
It or sometimes called a kettle drum
and it was playing two different pitches
actually sort of playing this
pitch and this pitch the octave.
And then the fifth,
the fifth degree of the scale after the
tonic is the next most important. Um,
and it's called the dominant,
the dominant note. Okay.
So that's what that is in that
particular quick question.
So the Timpani comes in and it goes crazy,
right?
Bom, Bom, Bom, Bom,
Bom, Bom, Bom, Bom, bom.
It comes back to the tonic. At which
point the trumpet takes over again.
So let's listen to just a little bit
more and I think, well, let's listen.
I forget where we left off.
Okay, let's stop it
here. Now at this point,
what happens is the trumpet fall.
Hello
all the way up there. It's
going to jump way, way up. Uh,
so let's listen to that.
Okay.
Stop
that right here. What's happening?
It interests me acoustically. Again,
we'll come back to it.
Is that we're getting up toward here
and notice how these pitches in terms of
their fruit ratio frequencies
are getting very close together.
So we're going to go
bomb
you sing the next note
bomb. There it is up there. Okay,
good. You got it. Come a louder. Um,
coraggio.
Okay, so there we are there.
My question on the quiz,
here's what's this one called?
Ah,
bomb.
Okay. So this is a, this is a leading
tone going in, into that particular ended,
that particular note.
So let's listen to hear again,
just the very end of this with the
spectacular sound of the orchestra.
[inaudible]
and they're at the end, you could
hear the organ a little bit better.
So that's how it using
some of these basic ratios,
he gives us this primordial type of
music and it's quite spectacular.
It's quite spectacular
because here in the 1890s,
we have the apex of the western
classical orchestra, this big, beautiful,
powerful instrument. Uh, okay.
We've talked a little
bit about pitch here.
Let's go on to talk about
the other axis of music.
And that is rhythm or duration.
Now in music,
as you probably know, we've already
talked a little bit about this. Um,
we have the importance of the beat beats,
very important in music and
generally speaking, in, in music,
we divide the beat,
we organize it into groups,
beats kind of like the heartbeat.
It's kind of like the basic pulse of
Bom, Bom, Bom, Bom, Bom, Bom, bom.
But w w given our psychological makeup,
we tend to divide these up into units
of January two and generally three.
And if we have groups of two,
we call that Dupo meter two to three,
we call that of course triple meter.
How do we indicate these?
Well by some kind of conducting pattern,
we'll come back to this. You'll all be
conducting in here. So [inaudible] one,
two, one two, one two, one
bom, Bom, Bom, Bom, Bom, Bom, Bom, Bom,
Bom Bom,
one strong beat, one weak,
be strong, weak, strong,
weak in that fashion.
And conversely of course triple is strong,
weak, weak, strong, weak, weak with
two week between each strong B.
So here's a question for you. Who wrote
the musical? It's on your quiz there.
Chicago. Anybody know the
answer to that? Ha. Okay. Uh,
how many, how many don't
know. Arousing show of hands.
You don't know who wrote Chicago?
This is amazing to me.
This guy is the stealth bomber of music.
How nobody could know the name of this
person that has given us so much great
music, cabaret, Chicago songs that
you go around singing in. You know,
having your ear all the time.
John Kander lives down in New York City,
writes them,
writes a lot of this stuff.
So we're going to listen to a track
out of John Kander Chicago here.
And the question,
uh,
that's an issue in play at the moment
is what's the meter of this cut from
Chicago?
[inaudible]
okay. Um, here's
something of May interest.
You will be playing a
lot of pop music in here,
but they will generally be short clips
of pop music. Why is that the case?
Yeah.
Big, big for copyright reasons,
right? Yeah. For copyright reasons.
So we've heard a passage
here. What was the, uh,
meter of that section?
Gentleman down here, you seem
to be moving with the music,
which is very good. What did
you think? Dupler triple. Okay.
DUPA now I would come to, that's correct.
I would come right back to you with,
yeah. You intuited that, but can you
explain to me what you were hearing?
What did you hear that allowed your
brain to instantly go to that decision?
Make that correct decision?
Any ideas? Anybody?
Okay. Cut Time. What accent on one.
But what part of the music
were you listening to?
Yeah, yeah. That's it. Some, but
somebody is actually going don, Don, Don,
and it's actually the base.
So we'll be wanting to zero in on the
base in a big way in music bum bump,
because that's oftentimes you're giving
as much more information than the Melody
Bom, Bom, Bom. So there we had
an example of Duplo. Let's see,
we got another extra here.
Let's listen to a little bit of that.
[inaudible]
so what about that one?
Yeah,
yeah. You know the setup here.
We did Dupal then we got to
do triple. Okay, so that,
but you can hear fun to the
strong, weak, weak, strong, weak,
weak in that fashion. All right, now
let's listen to a little bit more of this.
And something interesting happens
to the beat. It slows down,
what do we call the passage of
music in which the beat slows down?
What's being applied? What's being
affected here? What's being used here?
Okay.
Okay. Very simple word there. Retard.
Okay, so the music has retarded.
We have the,
the pulse being slowed down and almost
like a law of physics if something slows
down, an opposite and equal reaction. Now,
John Kander makes the music accelerate.
Oh,
so let's watch a wonderful
example of ECT, cello, Rondo here,
let me,
okay,
so at that point,
the music begins to speed up
with the Accela Rondo. Now, uh,
we're getting close as you might
imagine to the end. Indeed,
he wants to drive to the end.
Do you ever notice this?
And musical compositions keep an eye
out for this, particularly in pop music?
They've got an idea,
but they've got to fill up a track.
They really need three good three
minutes and 30 seconds here they'll have
something going and then
almost unbeknownst to you,
they will take that and lifted it up.
In terms of the pitch content,
what does that call when you change
the fundamental pitch in a ps,
going to a different pitch level?
Anybody know about that called modulation?
And this is sort of where it will be
really, really four months from now.
Modulation, it's very subtle, very
subtle. A lot of what we were doing.
Today's PR is very straight forward.
The idea of duplo versus triple meter,
but most modulations we don't
usually hear. So let's listen to,
we got two more cuts to do
and then I'll let you go. Uh,
let's listen to John Kander sit on one
pitch level and then suddenly raised the
whole thing up.
Raising up music builds excitement.
Yes,
yes.
Okay, let's stop there. Now he builds,
I think this is the last question.
What do we call this last chord when
we've already talked about if it's not the
tonic chord, it's the, anybody remembered
the second most important pitch,
that dominant. So let's watch John
Kander sit on the dominant chord now
[inaudible]
and now you seeing the tonnage.
MMM,
okay.
Hit the tonic.
[inaudible]
okay,
so these are the kinds of things we
will be doing if you decide to take this
course, get ahold of the
materials for next Tuesday.
Do listening exercises one and
nine through 11. I'll see you then.